In this exercise, you'll set up a diffused material. The sphere on this scene
starts with a solid color, unaffected by the lighting. To give this object a
diffused material, the first step is to change the material from three.js's
basic material to Lambert. The Lambert material has a few separate color
components. The equation that the Lambert material uses is, the color is equal
to ambient plus the material color times the sum of the normal dotted with each
light source. We're going to ignore the emissive component, since in practice,
that component is rarely used. In the exercise, you'll see code like this. This
code sets up the solid color. By switching this material to Lambert material,
the color set here is for the diffuse component. You could also explicitly set
this color after creation with the following code, as usual. If you want the
value of one channel of the color, you can access it like this, for example.
This first term of the equation is the materials ambient color setting. The
ambient color is called, wait for it, ambient. The ambient color is multiplied
by the ambience light color, which I've set to white. Your task is to set this
ambient color to be the material color times 0.4. At the start of the exercise,
you'll see this, a flat shaded sphere. When you're done, you should see
something like this.